I'm absolutely delighted to be here at
the university of Brasilia so let's just
start with one of the simplest of
machines the wheel and this particular
example goes back many many thousands of
years but I'm not going to talk about
the wheel in any detail because we know
how important it is when I go to touch
on steam steam engines on electric
motors on internal combustion engines on
diesel engines on jet engines and
rockets on our own biological motors
which have been around for a long long
time longer than any of these artificial
machines and then those that are close
to my heart
molecular artificial machines and by no
means is this the end of the story we
can look to the future and these gaps
have to be filled in so if we start by
looking at steam engines then the bottom
left-hand corner shows one that was
brought into being by fellow Scot James
Watt back in 1765 this one in 1883 was
used in the northern parts of
Pennsylvania in the United States to
pump oil and then quite soon afterwards
these engines took to Rails and you see
up in the top right-hand corner a very
famous locomotive it's the Stephenson
rocket and if you go to the Science
Museum in London
you can feast your eyes on this 18:29
this is where steam engine on wheels
let's now look at further advances in
that here here is an example of the
Flying Scotsman which allowed the
journey between London and Edinburgh
where I was born in Scotland to take
place in six hours
this was transformative at the time and
here is an example of a
steam engine is still used today in
Oregon for tourists to be able to go
around that state and enjoy the scenery
electric motors well here is a device
that was first devised by Michael
Faraday that shows how to transfer
electric energy into motion here is the
first electric motor that was invented
by a Hungarian Janos edge lake back in
1827 here is an example of an electric
motor was a gift of James Joule to Lord
Kelvin back in 1842 but it was a half a
century later before the first hair
dryers came on the scene and now of
course we have electric cars and in
addition to having electric cars if you
go to China you find that they have a
transport system that connects 60 cities
the size of New York it happened very
very quickly by high-speed rail into
Shanghai high-speed train has even
clocked in speeds up to 400
that's about 300 miles an hour awesome
absolutely awesome if we come to the
internal combustion engine
then here is an early patent by Vaughn
Langham a German engineer that within a
very short period of time find its way
into cars and here is the first one that
was available to the masses in America
about seventeen and a half million of
these forties were sold between 1908 and
1928 and in more recent times here is my
own Toyota Corolla and what is
interesting
once you with a Nobel Prize you
immediately get a special place to park
your car diesel engines so I went
putting this talk together that it comes
from the name of rig of diesel a German
who invented the first diesel engine
back in 1893 and nowadays these diesel
engines are used to power big big cargo
ships that are moving across our oceans
if we now turn to jet engines then
British inventors of Sir Frank Whittle
whose name is inexorably linked to their
discovery invention if you like gives us
a situation where nowadays and here you
see taking off is an f-22
fighter and at the same time you see
landing at London Heathrow a Boeing 787
dreamliner having made the journey from
Perth in Australia some nine thousand
miles non-stop in 17 hours just
absolutely incredible now here is
something that will interest you I hope
at any one instance in time there are
12,000 of these contraptions in the air
and if we put 200 250 people in each
there are two and a half million there
is the population of Brasilia not on
land here but up in the air think about
it
amazing rocket engines so they came into
being rather sadly during a war about in
more recent times in 1969 we had the
first landing on the moon by about
Aldrin and Neil Armstrong and then very
close to me is the fact that a young
student Helen Charmian was the first
student or first astronaut to be put
into space courtesy of the Russian
cosmos event all right so now I want to
just step back and look at biological
motors for a minute so here is the
system that allows us to move our
muscles actin and myosin but they have
to be powered by another rotary motor so
the first one is a linear one and the
second one is a rotary one which takes
adenosine diphosphate and phosphate and
makes
adenosine triphosphate and this is the
chemical is that where a store of energy
in our bodies and all of us adults in
the audience are creating
up to 40 kilograms of adenosine
triphosphate every day now it doesn't
become a huge burden because as we
create it we use it in flexing our
muscles and so forth but if we are a
sports person then we will create our
body weight of ATP each day so here we
see Serena Williams at Wimbledon back in
winning the women's singles
and then no guessing who I picked for
the mail Scott Andy Murray again in 2016
winning the men's final and both of whom
producing enormous amounts of adenosine
triphosphate in order to accomplish
these feats let's go back to molecules
so I'm going to be talking today about a
particular type of molecule that has
mechanical bonds to it we call the
mechanically interlocked molecules or
MEMS for short and they're made by using
the recognition between molecules the
stickiness that brings them together
makes them self assemble and this all
happens under the direction of a
template and along the bottom you see a
complex we call this a pseudo Rotax aid
and with a little imagination you can
see how two big Stoppers can come on and
we make something called or attack sane
or we just take the blue linear part of
the proceed or attack scene and prick it
into a circle and we have a katha name
so my road map today is going to be the
following we're going to look at 35
years of research summary that has led
to micro machines and we may if time
permits look at radical recognition and
how it has led to molecular pumps will
look at jewel pumps very very briefly
and I'll say a thing or two about the
nature of the mechanical bond and if
time permits something about engines
time lines and reflections all right so
let's start with the 35 years of summary
it started for me when I was out of
academia for three years at the Imperial
chemical industries corporate laboratory
in Cheshire in the UK and it was there
believe it or not that I fell in love
with a weed killer
paraquat also called meteorologist
there's a highly deficient source of
electrons in an aromatic setting and I
painted blue and it falls in love with
anything that is PI electron rich
for example this map saline derivative
1/5 diamond aux-in absolutely and the
outcome is that red lights blue and blue
right sorry and we use this principle to
build in the first place a large macro
cycle we call it best para phenylene 34
Trenton or bpp 34 c10 for short and here
you see in the top right hand corner
an x-ray crystal structure in a
space-filling format of that ring system
and you can see of how if we present it
with paraquat the paraquat gets trapped
inside in a very very suggestive manner
if I take my fingers and form a ring the
paraquat is pointing through like that
and when you see that image you already
see we're well on the way to making a
mechanical bond we just have to put
large stoppers on the end or we create
another ring system which is on the
right hand side which is a blue
component built up of two paraquat units
linked by para xylene units and no
surprise red units like to go inside
this particular blue unit so we can put
by 1987 boo inside red and by 1988 red
inside blue so we're poised ready to
make catenin Xandra taxanes so here's a
movie just to perhaps animate what i'm
talking about here is paracord myth of
our origin is the other name for this
compound finding a home inside this rate
of micro cycle
so we can put glue inside red let's turn
it round and we have what we call the
little blue box and we can put red
things that love this blue box inside
the blue box but the blue box is not
easy to make because it's very very
highly strained and so we make it in the
presence of a template which we then
remove afterwards now if we instead of
having a string with red on it we have a
ring and there it is on the right hand
side I call it a template this is bpp 34
round 10 and we have the constituents to
make the blue box up in the left-hand
corner they don't talk to each other but
as soon as a covalent bond is formed
between a nitrogen and a carbon atom
with the loss of a bromide we get
essentially a derivative of the paraquat
and we know that it wants to live inside
this red ring and so it worms its way
inside and these vertical lines show
that it is finding weak interactions but
nonetheless important interactions to
hold that thread in that ring and we
just need to close another nitrogen
carbon bond which is the next thing that
happens and we were mechanically
interlocked molecule we have a two
Canton E and amazingly it was delivered
to us in the first reaction this doesn't
happen very often in a 70 percent yield
nowadays we can make it quantitatively
and what was even more stunning was when
we saw the picture from x-ray
crystallography of how the rings were
placed with each other we realized that
we were into a very very exciting period
because in that picture on that front
cover of anger on túcume you can see
from the blue component up in the
Northeast down to the red one in the
southwest blue red blue red separated by
three and a half angstroms this is the
same separation distance that our bases
have in our DNA so there's nothing so
different between the artificial world
and the natural world were using the
same weak interactions and so here's a
movie that shows how these components
come together and finally close that
carbon nitrogen bond and we have a to
Canton II so once this is made it is
rich in relative movements the fastest
one that's occurring about two million
times a second is a rocking motion of
the red ring with respect to the plane
of the blue ring the second one which is
a little slower occurring about a
thousand times a second and it can be
clockwise or anti-clockwise they call it
pirouetting this is the second one the
third one which is the slowest one of
all happening about 30 times a second
then these are all numbers at room
temperature is the circum rotation of
the red ring through the blue ring so
after we had made a turret axon and
sorry to ketamine and revealed its
potential we next made a tour attack
scene and here on the right hand side
you see the template the dumbbell
component that I've drawn in a very
appropriate way in order for the same
chemistry that we saw and making the
kattiline to be formed to make or to be
used to form a turret taxane now it
doesn't happen so efficiently because
this dumbbell although I draw it like
that is waving around and it's not so
pre-organized and therefore not so
liable to give a good outcome but
nonetheless at 32 percent on a first
trial that was a good delivery and so
again I show the movie that shows how
the
linear component is trapped within the
ring and we've made our first attack
seen now let me redraw this in a linear
way and what you're looking at here is
what we called a molecular shuttle
there's blue ring which is on this red
station as I might call it that on the
left hand side moves to the one on the
right hand side and it moves back and
forward and this is happening about
2,000 times a second so this is the
first example of a potential or
prototype of a linear motor and you
haven't seen this in this movie however
the ring moves back and forward between
these two red stations now if we replace
two identical stations with two
different ones so we make a bigger red
one and one that is green and the one
that is green which is called benzidine
likes the blue better than the red and
so at room temperature it spends 84% of
its time on the green the blue ring and
only 16% on the red so this is what we
call a non degenerate
molecular shuttle and so again the movie
shows that it spends a little time on
the red and a lot of time on the green
but we can take this particular system
to the next stage because we can speak
to the green unit we can speak either
electro chemically which I don't show
here or we can add some acid and if we
add some acid the protons will be
attached to the nitrogen and they will
become positively charged and then
Coulomb's law of physics comes in to PA
and tells the ring leave the green go to
the red and of course the green becomes
a different color this sort of broke
cover so here is the moving showing the
molecular switch in action how it
we'll spend a lot of its time on the red
provided the green has been protonated
and had been given a positive charge so
that was the beginning of the 35 years
of research summary the next part that I
want to mention involves radicals and I
want to just introduce because I want to
get over here that increasingly as my
career has unfolded it's not about me
it's about the students that's worked
for me it's about us it's about them and
one of these people is this man Elektra
Bocek who came from the Lebanon he got
his PhD degree in Strasbourg in France
before joining me at UCLA and then
moving to Northwestern University and by
this time I was giving my students and
postdocs a huge amount of freedom and he
carried out an experiment that someone
else in the group destroyed was being
intellectually disruptive he asked
himself if I take the blue box stoddard
group have been playing around with for
all these years and presented with
paraquat is there a way by which I can
get them to like each other and yes
there was if he used think dust and
reduced the amount of charge and formed
what we call radical cations their
outcome was we formed this Tris radical
tri cationic complex with very much
stabilization in terms of kilocalories
per mole 6 kilocalories per mole it was
a major breakthrough and it allowed us
to go on and make molecular machines in
the bottom left-hand corner you see the
crystal structure of this radical
species and what is more and this is
another story it forms an infinite stank
you have a very highly conducting
material which we have explored in other
directions so all I want to do here is
the other message across the young
people that get yourself into an
environment where you have enough
freedom to express your creativity
because that's what I've allowed many of
my subsequent students and I think you
will see 13 or 14 of them here to follow
in the footsteps of a leachable see who
founded the radical school in 2010 at
Northwestern so in the introducing of
these radicals as I say we Hank this
very very strong complex of over six
kilocalories per mole and what we can do
is that we can use it to form a
so-called energy ratchet so that we can
bring a ring on to a pseudo dumbbell
these dumbbells are equipped with
Stoppers that are not big enough to stop
rings coming on one is charged and it's
on the left hand side in this diagram on
the right and the other is neutral the
neutral one is green and if you carry
out a reduction and then a relaxation
process followed by an oxidation and
another relaxation process you can move
this ring from the left hand side across
to the right hand side and this is part
of what you have to solve in order to be
able to make them like the machine and
so that allowed us to design them like a
pump where this diagram shows the making
of it so on the left hand side of the
long linear component we have this part
which is ready to accept the ring
provided we reduce the charge down from
6 overall positive charges to free and
form this tris radical tri cationic
complex and then once we get it on there
if we oxidize it'll want to and has to
depart by the right-hand side it has to
go over aesthetic barriers
times I go with a speed bump and when it
goes over it is trapped on a long chain
it's not lost into solution and so the
energy keeps rising in this system we've
made a molecular machine ok so here's
another movie that shows how the ring
has come on and it is purple when it
comes on then when it's blue it has been
oxidized and it goes over the speed bump
purple it comes on the one Ramon already
wanted to come back the speed bump stops
it the second one joins it and so if we
go through steps we reduce we oxidize we
heat and we reduce we oxidize and we
heat again and we have two rings on this
dumbbell we've made a molecular pump
we've made them like a machine okay so
here is the chemical constitution of
this pump written across the top of this
slide and if you're asking what is the
experimental evidence it's obtained in
solution by a technique called proton
nuclear magnetic resonance and we see
this trace that one obtains after one
cycle of reduction and oxidation and you
can see that the ring is sitting ready
with some heat and we're working at 42
degrees centigrade to pass over the
speedbump
onto the collecting chain and these
Highfield on the right hand side signals
tell us when it has all passed over the
speed bump takes one and a half hours to
do this and we can repeat it and we can
get the second ring on and so now we
have a molecular machine and I use a
movie just to get the message across
when it's purple it brings the ring on
when it's blue we have restored the
positive charge and we use thermal
energy to get it over the speed bump
onto the collecting chain
we're going to bring the second one on
now it was purple now it's blue and it's
going to with thermal energy making its
way over the speed bump onto the
collecting chain so in summary we can
pump one ring followed by two rings and
in doing this we're doing chemistry away
from equilibrium now our biological
motors are all working away from
equilibrium if they weren't we wouldn't
be sitting here as live human beings
it's very important that we look at
systems that are pushing themselves away
from equilibrium and to summarize that
first ring comes on in ninety percent
yield and it crosses a barrier of 23
kilocalories per mole to get there after
a redox cycle involving reduction with
zinc an oxidation with nitrous or
hexafluorophosphate and if we repeat
that whole process the second ring comes
on with 85 percent yield overall the
yield of the final Theory taxane down in
the bottom hand corner is 77% but the
most interesting thing from this
experiment is that the barrier for the
second ring coming on is within
experimental error at 23.1 kilocalories
per mole the same as the first one a 23
point zero in other words the presence
of the first string on the collecting
chain is not inhibiting the passage over
to get the second ring and so if we go
from here to a thought experiment and
this is further than we yet
in experimental terms we can bring on by
reduction and oxidation juggling about
with energy barriers wandering and then
we can repeat this whole process and
notice how the energy landscape changes
and how as we bring on the third one the
level of the
energy expression Rises so we bring on a
fourth and it continues to rise and so
the conclusion is that each cycle has
trapped wandering in a very high energy
state some of the energy input is
trapped some will have gone to heat and
finally we can say work has been done
we've made a molecular machine this
leads to very interesting materials
called entropically dominated poly Rotax
ames now in the lab today will be people
working on what we call jewel pumps with
polymers in the middle with these pumps
on either end and they'll be bringing
rings on one after the other - is it
where fill up all the spaces along a
polymer chain and there's very good
reasons why we want to do that there's
good reasons and material science
there's good reasons in factories and
energy science I'm not going to have
time because of the clock to go there
today I just complete my story by saying
now we're pumping rings onto polymers
they come on from each end
we got molecular pumps we've got
machines that have been made
artificially at each end and you can see
these rings being collected on this long
polymer chain so what I want to do is
simply end with a summary where I define
the icons that I'm going to use I'm not
going to be talking you're going to be
listening to a video with some music and
when you see a padlock with a key
outside like a recognition is switched
off when the key is in the lock
it is switched on and remember the
interaction between red and blue that is
what we call donor-acceptor recognition
will also have temptation and I use this
symbol here these are the symbols that
we used to use before we had
sophisticated ways of drawing chemical
structures with computers called
ChemDraw
we used to have these templates to draw
ring systems by hand so that's the icon
are used for temptation and then you saw
how important the radical recognition
became in the design of the molecular
pump and the fact that when the radicals
are featureing we have a purple system
we will use heat and we will also use
electricity will use redox control -
volts plus volts and will sometimes see
ratios which is all with the degenerate
sorry nondegenerate molecular shuttle of
4 to 1 and then how you can change
switching with acid and base so at this
stage I'm going to close with a video
that will I hope leave you with a
summary of what I've talked about and
hopefully I managed to get my message
across
so please enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Bali
[Music]
take a bow
thank you
we don't need to do anything else we
could just sit here and enjoy the dance
really
that was beautiful um we have a little
time for Question and Answer and please
I encourage you to use the time to ask
questions I would just like to start
though by saying you showed all these
pictures of this lovely diverse group of
young people in your lecture and then
you just showed us how social science
can be yes I guess that's I mean that
must be such a source of pleasure just
having this wonderful diversity of
people coming through the lab all the
time yes them it is what has made my
life so enjoyable I would almost say
that it has displaced my and our because
it has been a team effort achievements
and research the opportunity to get
together over 50 years with over 500
young people some of the smartest in the
planet in the SAP may have come from
Brazil as well as other countries has
been an enormous privilege so 50
different nationalities from 50
different countries and 500 I've really
been very fortunate
it's an enormous ly big family and when
I go to airports now very often there
are quite a few of these eggs family
members there to greet me it's very
moving
[Music]
how can molecule machines be applied in
industry or in our daily lives so
they've already found application in
material science some Japanese workers
have used these polymers that I've been
showing you where rings slide back and
forth and they call them slide ring
polymers and they're already being
quoted in Japan on the back of cell
phones and the reason that they are
being quoted on the back is that as a
material is scratched then in front of
your very eyes the scratch will fill up
and this is because the rings on the
polymer can move and in moving make the
material scratch resistant that's one
example another example that has been
published recently using the same kind
of slide ring polymers is to increase
the efficiency of lithium ion batteries
by inhibiting the coalescing in the
battery medium of silica nanoparticles
again because of the movement of the
ring system so we already see in the
materials field applications and I
should perhaps have said first of all
that there are very major applications
back into chemistry itself so the area
of what we call stereo chemistry has
been revolutionized by the discovery of
an invention of the mechanical bond in
the future we will see big applications
I predict in the health sciences
professor Christian who has all set for
for you to Steve face to me it Oprah
Becky little statue military ashiya-kun
magnetism she was she was just a comment
to say that there was an earlier
demonstration electricity
magnetism oh all right well I'm has good
I think bye-bye she was kind of saying
professor Christian hands oh right I
wonder if that was Hans Christian
Andersen I'm not sure please go ahead
your question please which properties do
you look at when designing them like a
machine for instance I imagine that the
Rotax scene could be used in signal
transmission so do you have any
computational chemistry chemists helping
you in the design I'm sorry you're gonna
have to repeat that a little bit more
slowly just the question sorry so which
properties do you look at when designing
micro machines for instance I believe
the Rotax Eames could be used in signal
transmission so do you have a
computational chemist helping you in
your group with the design I did so it's
which properties do you look at when
designing a molecular machine for
instance with their attacks Eames
there's a potential relationship to
signal transmission do you have a
computational chemist working with you
oh yes we work collaboratively with Bill
Goddard at Caltech you know
internationally recognized computational
chemist and he runs a very big group of
70 or 80 people so we work very closely
with computational chemists we do some
computation ourselves but we don't
pretend to be you know the world's best
and so if you're in that position you
seek the collaboration of the people you
consider to be the intellectual leaders
in the field so yes we do
use computational chemistry all those
all those times in machine development
bring approaches and procedures which
would be the challenges that people
coming from mechanics and electricity
those other fields faces in intervene in
developing a new approach in
no technology or which challenges you
face when you have to come to work with
those people coming from these other
fields
well this an excellent opportunity for
me to state that I think the advent of
nanotechnology which I would give the
credit in large measure to the
physicists who in the late eighties
brought a scanning tunneling microscopes
and atomic force microscopes into being
the group at IBM in Zurich and of course
this was recognized by quite
appropriately a Nobel Prize also I would
say that the development of what became
known thanks to Joel marilaine 1987
laureate in chemistry of supramolecular
chemistry these two developments one in
chemistry and one in physics I think
made it possible for nanotechnology to
become a uniting force across physics
and chemistry and to also quite
naturally embrace biology and
engineering and so what has been one of
the big throws of my academic life as to
watch how we went from being very much
in silos and boxes and not talking to
each other if I go back to the 70s and
maybe the early eighties to the time
that we find ourselves in today where I
would say there is largely a seamless
interaction between scientists brought
about under the umbrella I would say of
nanotechnology across the spectrum from
wherever you want to start biology
chemists
physics material science materials
engineering thank you very much indeed
okay so we have a question up here and
then one down here please
AB on gh2 the postage I gotta say poor
partially Bacchus or so Pesky's it was
rich sapping our people to BC positivism
poco a pension HR so to magistrates a
bitcoin of regime we there's a for TVs
Iraqi fighters motorists biological even
moleculus movie my diary he calls for eg
we pokey Karzai GG model totally
changing its processor to movement asana
straight for question what is the fault
yes that moves the molecular machines it
is there naturally these are very small
entities these are small molecules and
so they are subject to what we often
call Brownian motion and so it's not a
question of making the parts move it's a
question of controlling their movement
so that you dampen down movements that
are already there and so if I take the
molecular shuttle as an example I may
portray it in pictures as being discrete
a ring moving from there to there but
really what it's doing this ring is
going back and forward like that on one
station then back and forward like this
on the other station and so what we do
is look at a situation where the
molecules are almost living in the face
of a hurricane and we need to dampen
down that movement in order to be able
to control it and then use it
so the movement situation is a given
because of the laws of physics sir
student congratulations for your
brilliant presentation
I'm Philippi from the Brazilian Ministry
of science technology and innovation in
our department is the charge of public
policies for nanotechnology so in terms
of public policies with are your advices
to us
in order to incorporate in our nation
our strategy for another technology
thank you
he's from the ministry and it's the
question what are the what what is your
advice for science policy for Brazil I
have a very strong message to deliver
here the last 60 years and it was
enshrined by the scientific advisor to
Franklin D Roosevelt in 1945 after World
War two he made the point and this was
the basis for the formation of the
National Science Foundation in the
United States that the best way to look
for advancement in science was to fund
people rather than to focus your money
onto projects that were and somehow
perceived by often not front rank
scientists not people who are working at
the cutting edges and therefore taking
the people away from the freedom to be
able to express their creativity and I
speak from the heart because for these
last 10 plus years I have run a research
group with a huge amount of freedom we
have made two serendipitous when I say
we to people within that cohort have
made two serendipitous discoveries and
we now have two startup companies as a
result of giving the freedom to the
researchers to be creative and to do
their own thing this will always win out
over very highly directed research
wherever it comes from in my humble
opinion and I've often said the
nation-state that results back to
supporting people rather than projects
will have many Nobel laureates
[Applause]
[Music]
okay the absolute they thank you Hosea I
won't hear the question though oh I
would not want to make such an
outrageous claim that it would bring the
end of diseases that are seen to be the
degenerative diseases like cancers and
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and so forth
I think these are very very big
challenges that face the human race the
solutions are not going to be the magic
bullet that we saw almost 50 60 70 years
ago when antibiotics were brought to our
into our lives and saved of course many
many lives and I always illustrate the
advent of antibiotics by saying if
you're sitting in an audience like this
Luke 2 the person on your right and the
person on your left and prior to the
advent of penicillin and its followers
these two people would not be there so
that was transformative I don't see that
immediately happening in the context of
the degenerative diseases I think the
challenge is very much bigger I speak
from the heart Hosea I lost my own wife
from breast cancer after a 12-year
battle and whatever anyone says the
treat
is still and I will be very blunt here
almost medieval it is slash burn and
poison that is surgery radiation and
chemotherapy and we need to advance
beyond that point and I'm sure that the
people here in the pharmaceutical
industry particularly those from Astra
Zeneca are probably pursuing new ways
and all power to their elbows in order
to address these degenerative diseases
but remember they come into being
because we're all living much older and
you have got to ask yourself have we the
right to be able to live longer and
longer we already have a problem with
population growth in the planet and
there are many many questions I think
that your question raises other than
just directly saying yes molecular
machines are going to solve it or no
they're not they were going to play a
part but it's going to take a lot more
and many people working collaboratively
to so major problems and for letting you
see a Nobel Prize dancing in front of us
that was very brilliant
my question is complimentary to the
young my young colleague here in the
presence of Astra Zeneca which is one of
the big farmers we start thinking what
do you have what should we expect from
this molecular engines in the medical
field in the future would it be nano
sized surgeons what was a surgeon what
should we expect you would it be nano
sized Serge yes yes I think that is a
good phrase I would dream and I have to
emphasize this is dreaming of
development where these artificial
machines would to use your terminology
in
we small surgeons I would say molecular
prosthetics and so just as we've gone
through a time in the last 50 years
where we can translate hearts and
kidneys and livers and we can replace
hip joints and knees and so forth we're
going to be working I think medically at
a much smaller level with these nano
machines which are going to be able
given enough time and enough development
to address the attack on cells and
particularly of course disease cells so
it'll be a much more active way of
bringing about drug delivery than we
know at present I'm not saying there
isn't that it's all passive but the fact
that we will be able to use almost
little many propellers to drill through
cell walls I think that could be
transformative in terms of the treatment
of degenerative diseases that coming
back to the question that we had from
Jose okay oh gosh they're all the
questions are coming now we haven't got
very long quick questions then you then
you okay three more I can see quickly
all right I would like to ask because
you've been researching this for 35
years which evidently is a lot of time I
would like to ask you when you started
the research in the eighties did you
already see the deep theoretical
ramifications that would it would have
and they're also their practical
applications you do we're already see
that in the eighties or it became more
evident as the research developed oh
very quickly I did not see what was
coming I never claimed to be able to see
him very much beyond 18 months ahead and
even then I would be pushing it you know
it's much more an incremental process
you have to undergo as you start out at
university at least 10 years 10,000
hours of a
apprenticeship to get to be familiar
with the particular signs that you
decide to are engineering or whatever to
focus your attention on and after that
or while that's happening you start to
think about what is the big problem that
I might address that if I were
successful will be a contribution to
science a contribution to humanity you
really have to ask yourself that
question too many people put it off or
never ask it and they continue to follow
the footsteps and go down the beaten
tracks of others here so it is
absolutely important that you ask
yourself is there a big problem out
there if you identify it get involved in
some risk-taking and address it thank
you thank you last two questions but
here quickly
please where's the microphone and then
this okay sorry you had one I'm sorry
okay so first of all I would like to
thank you search be here it's honor
great we being honor so I study
aerospace engineer here in the
university and one of the major problems
we have it's about to carry weight into
space and we are coming to you in 2021
and so to go to Mars and I would like to
know if you sir any perspective of your
molecular engines into the aerospace
industry use I think we're not on the
same level in terms of scale so forgive
me being negative but I don't
immediately see an application for nano
machines in terms of splicer exploration
if we're talking about the bread and
butter of getting Rockets up into space
of course if we're talking about what
happens inside a space craft or space
capsule then
well surely there'll be human beings
there and then we'd be discussing that
there may well be something that relates
to their diets or their health or
whatever these artificial machines can
play a part so that's about all I think
in say I think I will pass on that yes
congratulations for your wonderful talk
which advises which take-home message
would you give for young students and
young scientists to not give up science
though she wants to take home message
good perfect yeah yeah take-home message
for young scientists encourage them not
to give up science yeah okay so you'll
have to be I think engaged at a level of
enormous emotion and passion you know I
was an only child
and I think to some extent I was given
the opportunity being brought up also in
the countryside to dream about what I
might do with my life
and as I zeroed in on science these
dreams continued and whatever comes in
your path that may be presenting a
difficulty your dreams have got to be
such that they propel you on in an
optimistic way if you'll excuse the flee
it's come hell or high water that
nothing will stop you you have to be
driven you know after my first taste of
doing research in other poetry in 1963
when I was 21 years of age it didn't
become something that I liked it became
an addiction I could not take myself
away from the laboratory in the evening
and I couldn't get back to it sooner in
the
morning that passion has exist for the
remaining 55 or 60 years maybe not the
laboratory but to get back to my office
and to be beside the young people just
by walking a few steps along to the
laboratory and I'm very lucky to be able
to interact with these wonderful people
between 18 and 32 we are some of the
brightest and the planet and so however
you look at it and it changes in it's
perfect as you live your life there is
so much in the way of enjoyment so much
in the way of absolute fun to have just
from committing yourself in a passionate
way to the level of addiction to science
thank you very much indeed Frasier for
taking time away from the lab to share
your passion with us all thank you
you